hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey it was my birthday yesterday
well I say thank you again to everyone
who paid me money to Ching for turning
an age thank you to all you guys you
guys are wonderful wonderful followers
of the channel thank you so much for
your support Ashley and her longtime
friend gave me this shirt so thank you
so much for the birthday present my dear
we're gonna watch the honest trailers
for the conjuring which perfectly fits
for our lifestyle right now because we
have spent all weekend putting together
a vlog from our experience going through
the convent and the catacombs and
promotion for Warner Brothers the nun
which is all part of the conjuring
universe that video should be up some
time tomorrow still got some touch-ups
of doing it still got some editing to
trim down a little bit here and there if
we put a lot of work into it
dead meat James is featured in the video
corn hearted the director we were the
only group that he actually went through
the haunt with so we got an exclusive
with corn hardy there you guys got to go
check this video out of me in the world
to us bring that notification valve
click it to get notified when vlog is up
I felt my soul hurt on your behalf
speaking of screen junkies I'm supposed
to go back on movie fights with a third
time this year some point this month
maybe towards the end what's fine to
have people anyway the conjuring the
movie I've only seen one time many years
ago
haven't laughed at all today from the
director of that other horror franchise
starring Patrick senate-house comes to
film is based on the 100% true ghost
stories of Ed and Lorraine Warren what I
never say when her brother said of a
lawsuit against them because they almost
had to go to trial to prove that ghosts
were real are know whether doctor they
hear about that what engine hey Warren's
two of the least funny Ghostbusters but
damn Errol wrote that joke he's also
there it's so small and light I remember
tackle the biggest case of their lives
in conjuring one while in conjuring 2
they will tackle the other biggest case
of the universe the hell franchise is
working for glowing MCU styleshoots poop
their work so master of aliens engineer
that does the franchise's signature
touch extremely long sequences of
tension building silence it works most
relatable horror scenario possible come
on nobody anticipation born
give me scare balls to haunting tales
about families with so many kids you
won't keep any ones great except the
dude from all the space yes comparators
bought their homes without doing even
the most basic inspections I think we
have a cellar for tossing out any of the
old haunted furniture my ex-husband but
all the phone
with the house and got stuck living
which every haunted house cliche in the
book like creepy fall Lakes yeah
basement yeah Thank You sellers
creepy crawl spaces part of the plot
with the animals
creepy children's toys we be children
stories even more creepy children
stories to movies face off enough be
history to fill an actual history book
anyone who tried to take was a real
treat something you kept selling the
place yeah calls up myth and legend
these ones are laying on threatening and
they smell like to whether it's a way
that you can be haha
bet you know
or the ghost of Elvis Presley but you
can be sure that no matter what they're
capable of from an audition
jason'll stick to the conventional 3x
structure of most screenplays or kill a
dog
close enough so buckle up for a decent
horror
I forgot how it was that has an entire
wall it's been tossed ready to go
rock back strands studio horror the pigs
go Sooners probably work I mean they
couldn't be as for but is the ones on TV
right
my name is zak bagans slowly walking
downstairs
[Music]
lights going out and tension building
chairs moving around
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh oh that's right yeah what it's like
the loud bang bang oh and doors they go
[Music]
that's pretty good door sound John baby
well if those doors are rusty the rest
of the time residents look what you made
honking Doh eggs are not robots if
you're gonna spew spew in the biz with
your normal everyday voice held my voice
broke did my favorite crop of poll
conference
you know my favorite casting bits are
when they do like the whole starring
it's always when they they show the most
repetitive strokes that you'll see in
the movies and when they have like a
solid good collection to back it up
everything with those doors they got I
had like three different ones dedicated
to doors there were doors that wouldn't
open there were doors that would go
creak there were doors that would be
banged on and there were doors like they
go yes slamming or having that
repetition I think is part of what makes
honest trailers so brilliant is
specifically in those starring sections
it's fun to do the fun names and all
that yeah but in this one you just have
Patrick Wilson Vera Farmiga really there
of vagina that would have been a top are
coyote and Sarah barge ina is the
funniest one you could have used for the
starring for her Taizo Varginha they
have just a very unfortunate name I
don't know who you're hanging out you
never realized how much of a drinking
game the movies are until you sit down
with an honest trailer but watching all
this footage back and looking at the
creepy imagery because I've only seen
conjuring one into one time each in the
theaters you know I don't even remember
exactly what they were looking for it in
those other than there's a haunt there's
a family I don't remember a lot of the
plot and a lot of the fun scares that
come from it I remember the stuff I get
spin-offs or as announced spin-offs good
man the done Annabelle I remember those
things for the trailer moments that you
just like the clap clap and the match
and all that stuff yeah you saw a
million times in Lido there's a lot of
creepy imagery here that I was looking
at going I forgot how actually scary a
lot of part 1 & 2 are yeah I mean the
conjuring films overall in the little
universe they've spawned and they've
brought studio horror back in a big way
cuz I mean not a lot of big budgets or
Universal horror
yes are the universe can't wait for the
Invisible Man Bride of Frankenstein it
feels more like the invisible box office
numbers you know what I'm moving but
this was like a great return to like
studio level horror that was actually
scary that was actually enjoyable that
actually kind of utilized budget and
stuff like because when they're talking
about the haunted house tropes they're
filled all the haunted house cliches
like that's part of the charm though
with movies I mean they're gonna be
that's a genre where I'm just like well
you can't have a house movie without a
certain amount because it's I think the
reason why people will clown on the
conjuring movie specifically for that
specifically the conjuring is not
Annabelle or even the nun is because of
the fact that they thrive so much on the
warrants for real people and these are
true stories so when you mix in bunch of
haunted house cliches there's it opens a
door up for criticisms for how true is
all of this really really turn upside
down and smack the scene accurate is all
this when it's so cliche at the same
time I mean the conjuring to very much
overstep that boundary I felt like a bit
more grounded and oddly I mean I like
the second one more I feel like the
first one's a better fill it's a more
strained movie yeah the second one is
more as wild and yeah yeah the weird
thing is like as much as I respect the
conjuring films I know a lot of people
really love them as like the highest
echelon of what current horror is that
but honestly I return to and think back
on insidious more often than I do the
conjuring and I kind of feel like maybe
the conjuring to stuck with me a bit
better because it brings in some of
those insidious elements like The
Crooked Man is like totally funhouse out
of those yes which is just an element
that the first one doesn't have as much
like the first one is a bit more of
drama and the second conjuring is a bit
zanier they're talking about the
universe they have here whenever I'm
hearing conversations in any like movie
news channel or whatever and they're
talking about how Studios are constantly
trying to start a universe and everyone
wants to be Marvel and it never works I
never hear anyone bring up the conjuring
universe cuz they slipped it in under
our noses
but it's successful it's working it
works like they did it all where they
literally just had a spin-off that made
money and then they were like hey I
could do this bunched well there was a I
don't want to like drop names here
Steven I drop names here who I was
taught it is a there's a photographer
the director who's doesn't pretty good
amount of work and then he was talking
about how he was in communication with
James Wan when they were developing the
contouring from the beginning as a
universe a lot of people kind of think
that the conjuring movies suddenly
turned into a universe I think it was
around like right when they want to do
Annabelle like right after the success
of the first conjurer it might have been
when they did the first contra but was
very early on where they wanted to go
for a universe and they've pulled it off
it works I mean the Annabelle movies
were both hits one of them was a
critical and financial hit the conjuring
movies are critical and financial hits
everyone's very excited for the none
my nipples are so we watch it gets our
recommendation even people want to see
The Crooked Man like this is a universe
that's actually working but ever people
talk about everyone who wanted to be
like Marvel the Qadri universes or it
again though yeah I mean I think it just
goes to show that you can't get ahead of
yourself and you have to focus on the
movie you're making right now yeah as
well as the sequence that you want to
complete because so many cinematic
universes just crumble because they put
the cart before the horse you know yeah
and the none without embargoes if we go
in the apartment that movie can't talk
about it yet but I will say about that
film that I also thought was very clever
it's a it's a really good standalone
movie that's not bent on connecting to
the conjuring world but when it does
it's awesome there's just enough
connective tissue to make all these
movies gratifying in that sort of yeah
fire kind of way while not being so
in-your-face cuz even Marvel like for as
well as Marvel has rolled that wheel
there were still phases during their
operation where we were like I get it
stop with the crossovers yeah and yeah
the conjuring hasn't really done that
much lately oh the only I guess the only
joke you can make now is like any
character that's not the main ghost you
can now go that's probably gonna get
spin up but hey more power to them as
long as it works and for as long as
they're putting time and care into these
movies and as much as I'm enjoying the
universe I would like a conjuring three
I'm like yeah yeah cap it off right he
got to be at least year three conjuring
well let's get that Amityville in there
that's the thing this has been off but
there's something about having Patrick
Wilson and Vera Farmiga together that
that anchors the whole universe together
for yeah so yeah they are kind of the
heart and soul even in the movies
they're not in yeah I'm still thinking
of them anyway guys John Bailey great
job on the voiceover honest trailers
writers congratulations on another
wonderful honest trailer thank you so
much keep a look out for my movie fights
and keep a look out for our vlog please
check it out
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
check us out on patreon we got
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
it's got a lot of stuff over there would
love to have you become a patron jected
die